[Music]
many societies are growing more diverse
in Germany people now come from all over
the world to study and to work lots of
companies are hiring people from a wider
range of backgrounds Buddhist opening
companies are looking for a diversity
but for us that doesn't mean primarily
diversity among staff based on visible
characteristics it's more about the
creativity experience knowledge and
skills they can contribute people from
more than 60 countries work at Henkel
headquarters and there are sound
business reasons why so many nations are
represented the company sells body care
products and detergents all over the
world and people who come from Asia or
the Middle East know best what their
compatriots want to buy interesting is
that actually when people come from
different backgrounds different ways of
working they bring with them a lot of
expertise from different markets henkle
has launched an image campaign to
celebrate the diversity it promotes and
addresses haitihub
a while ago Henkel developed a shampoo
specifically for women in Muslim
societies we asked what does someone who
hides her hair under a cloth all they
need in terms of special care do we have
to adapt the formula deformity much like
English light again then we launched the
product on those markets octave apart
that never would have happened if it had
just been a group of Germans sitting
around discussing what to do
dispossessing hedge Olga dr. Voss
[ __ ] German universities are also
promoting diversity
Anita Benedict Emanuel is in her sixth
semester at the University of Duisburg
Essen
she's part of a program that takes on
school pupils from non-academic
backgrounds who want to study and
accompanies them through their time at
the University mentoring them along the
way this benefits young people from
German and immigrant families anita is
the first member of her family to go to
university her parents are from Srilanka
my attending Kinsey had guns down the
dolls my parents weren't very familiar
with the education system here and even
when my teachers tried to explain it it
still wasn't very clear afeared on
that's politically the program gave me
the information I needed and the
counselors here at the University told
us about the various courses of study we
could take that was really helpful yeah
I mean but I'm head coach for many young
people from immigrant backgrounds in
Germany getting ahead depends on getting
help many don't finish high school and
only around 10 percent pursue higher
education so the university also offers
tutoring for school children immigrant
families often do not speak German at
home yet command of the language is a
prerequisite for success six years ago
Miriam fakira and her family fled to
Germany from Afghanistan she wants to
become an engineer or architect that's
why she it was hard at first because I
didn't speak the language and everything
was so foreign to me and you hear people
say you'll never make it but by being in
this program with extra tutoring and
help from teachers and friends really
motivated me I realized I can make it
yeah that's talking about up everyday
around 300 youngsters come here for
tutoring and the number of requests far
outstrips the number of available slots
often combs rely on Allah we see a lot
of kids with a lot of potential then
they tell us how their school's deal
with them and it's pretty shocking what
does that often it's two other factors
also play a role the first is that they
don't get any support at home their
parents think they don't stand a chance
and second they often have deficits in
their knowledge of German so harnessing
diversity is all about tapping potential
whatever a person's cultural or ethnic
background over the past decades some
German companies have signed up to a
diversity charter in if they commit to
creating work environments free of bias
there are six dimensions described in
the charters list of voluntary
commitments the first is sex so men and
women and then there's age we usually
talk about the five generations of
people active in working life then
there's nationality and ethnic origin
religion and worldview sexual
orientation and identity and finally
disability bindle the goal is to give
every employee the same opportunities
and if promoting diversity is also good
PR so much the better
you
you